Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij eccoci
anche a me fa salire la nostalgia In
realtà quindi non è solo per voi come
come come va Come va Siamo cresciuti
tutti quanti insieme quindi ormai molti
di voi che mi hanno conosciuto
all'inizio no Quando ho iniziato a fare
video oltre 10 anni fa ormai ehm sono
adulti siamo adulti cioè io no però voi
sì questo No a parte gli scherzi sono
arrivato ad un punto della mia vita dove
non si capisce bene dove sto andando e
quindi è bene fare un punto della
situazione dove siamo Dove dove è
arrivato ehm favi j ok Oggi Dov'è
arrivato mi fa anche strano ormai dire
Favij non perché non mi senta più Favij
Ma perché ehm Quando uno dice Favij gli
viene in mente Happy Wheels Ok mi viene
in mente Happy Wheels va bene perché la
99% delle persone che mi fermano anche
in giro mi dicono no Favij sei la mia
infanzia Happy Wheels Ok queste tre cose
cosa succede
importante che sono stati 10 anni sono
passati 10 anni in cui ho fatto video
sui videogiochi Ok ogni giorno che per
me è una passione è ancora una passione
cioè io gioco ai videogiochi Adesso sto
giocando a baldus Gate lo finirò poi
giocherà a starfield cioè io gioco gioco
non è che non lo faccio Non lo faccio
più in video perché per due motivazioni
uno perché a furia di farlo nel tempo
era diventato un po' una catena di
montaggio nel senso ok Oggi mi siedo
devo trovare l'indie horror
possibilmente giusto e una volta fatto
quello va registrato montato caricate
così tutti i giorni Quindi man mano che
faccio questa cosa è diventata un po'
una sorta di catena di montaggio Ma ho
passato anni anche in cui magari lo
facevo un po' più sforzandomi in cui le
cose andavano super bene nel senso che
nido andavano comunque tantissimo finché
a un certo punto l'attenzione si è
giustamente abbassata perché dopo dieci
anni a fare sempre la stessa cosa è
enorme Anzi io nella mia testa pensavo
che sarebbe successo molto prima invece
è durato fin troppo quindi vi ringrazio
io addirittura di tutto questo supporto
durato piace tantissimo per quanto
riguarda i videogiochi pian piano hanno
iniziato a piacervi di meno ma perché il
Trend del pubblico è cambiato è normale
le persone crescono crescete anche voi
Così come io quindi diciamo che secondo
me la maggior parte delle persone a un
certo punto è arrivata Ci vuole molta
Secondo me maturità per capire questo
quindi non è detto che tutti quelli che
guardano Questo video lo capiscano
subito ma secondo me con il tempo lo
potrete capire Nel caso non è più una
questione di Favij mi piace perché fa i
Gameplay Favij mi piace perché so che è
stato un punto importante Un pezzo
importante della mia infanzia della mia
adolescenza è anche se non me li guardo
più
so che lui li sta facendo e quindi
questo in qualche modo mi fa sentire al
sicuro noi sappiamo che c'è una casa lì
ok un rifugio sicuro ok Favij che
qualsiasi cosa io stia facendo nel mondo
oggi mi sto ehm sto diventando grande
sto facendo tante cose mi approccio al
mondo del lavoro ehm sto combattendo le
mie battaglie perché la vita non è
semplice so che indipendentemente da
quello che mi sta succedendo Favij Oggi
ha fatto uscire un video di Gameplay ok
questa cosa in qualche modo nella mia
testa mi dà sicurezza c'è una persona un
amico un fratello un qualcuno che sta
facendo una roba
che mi dà sicurezza perché perché ha
fatto parte della mia infanzia ormai è
qua e non lo si può togliere più ok né
come di Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
Favij non esiste Quindi questa cosa io
la capisco la capisco perché Perché
anche io ho trovato in quello un rifugio
Nel senso che fare la stessa cosa tutti
i giorni comunque e sapere di
intrattenere così tanto
mi ha sempre fatto sentire in qualche
modo
utile alle persone non solo perché
magari ricevo dei messaggi mi ha aiutato
in un bel periodo e di questo vi
ringrazio perché anche voi Avete aiutato
me ma è anche perché anch'io sono
nostalgico anche io quando dico bella a
tutti ragazzi Sono nostalgico anch'io
quando guardo un video di Happy Wheels
non lo guardo però per dire Ogni tanto
mi capita no e dico magari leggo solo il
titolo e vedo la copertina di un mio
video vecchio dico che bel periodo sono
nostalgico anche io ma questo non può
funzionare oggi perché lo vedete anche
voi nel senso ci sono dei videogiochi
che io comunque ho portato perché
attenzione Io non ho detto non li
porterò mai più Ho detto se un gioco mi
ispira a tal punto che per me non è
catena di montaggio creare quel
contenuto io lo faccio Infatti ho fatto
residentivolo perché mi è piaciuto e mi
è piaciuto tantissimo ed è andato da
cani perché molte meno persone oggi
apprezzano quel tipo di contenuto perché
il Trend è cambiato Ci sta cioè è
normale
però l'ho fatto lo stesso e me ne sono
[__] perché mi è piaciuto Ok qual è
la direzione attualmente e qui arriviamo
al punto nel senso che io oltre un anno
fa ho fatto uscire questo video in cui
ho detto che avrei smesso di fare i
videogiochi Ma che la mia strada sarebbe
andata in un'altra direzione e qual è
questa direzione Non lo so Ok Non lo so
perché Da un anno a questa parte io cosa
ho fatto e cosa sto tuttora facendo Sto
sperimentando sperimentare vuol dire
provare a fare cose e vedere che cosa Mi
stimola di più perché e vi svelo questo
segreto non è facile sapere cosa si
vuole a livello editoriale a livello
artistico perché quando fai una cosa per
10 anni io per i videogiochi poi perdi
un po' la concezione di quello che
potrebbe piacerti quindi lo devi
scoprire Ok tu hai passato il tempo a
fare sembra la stessa cosa Poi apri la
porta e ci sono milioni di cose dici Ok
Che figo cosa mi piace fare boh Devo
provare a vedere da quando ho smesso di
fare i videogiochi fino adesso ho fatto
diversi contenuti senza un reale Format
ma li ho fatti perché mi piacevano
Quindi ho fatto dei video molto più
elaborati nel singolo video però non
hanno una vera direzione artistica Cioè
se uno mi chiede oggi cosa sai che video
fai Io dico boh non lo so più che Vito
faccio perché faccio i video che mi
piacciono Ok quindi non è che ogni
venerdì posso fare uscire un video di
quelli che ho ad esempio ho portato fino
adesso o che ne so magari vado in
Giappone faccio il vlog del Giappone Ma
non è che posso andare cioè non il mio
non è un canale di traveling Ok io posso
andare a fare un video un blog mentre
sono in giro ma quello deve essere un
extra non può basarsi che non sono Human
Safari il mio canale non si può basare
su video di traveling perché non faccio
quello quello è un extra come lo era
quando c'è i videogiochi ogni tanto
andavo a Los Angeles facevo il blog di
Los Angeles ho il vlog in Giappone Ma
non è che quello è il mio Focus quella è
una cosa che mi piace fare a me perché
io amo viaggiare posso portarvi dei
contenuti così quando magari vado in
giro ma è una cosa in più manca il core
Ok il core e nel mentre vediamo che
strada prendere ma è una cosa che sto
facendo con pazienza perché io oggi ho
la fortuna di poter stare magari
tranquillo e di capire che direzione
prendere senza dover per forza lasciare
perché ho lavorato 10 anni diciamo un
po' sulla cresta di cui sei sulla cresta
dell'onda sei sette quindi posso
permettermi di capire cosa fare adesso
quindi non fare le cose di fretta
ed era questo il mio obiettivo tra
l'altro Quindi tutto giusto però sono
sereno ecco Quello sicuramente quindi
dopo che è andato tutto così bene e la
vita è una sola non la puoi passare a
fare una cosa che magari non ti soddisfa
al 100%. quindi devi bisogna cambiare ok
bisogna mutare
è necessario secondo me cioè
indipendentemente anche Forse dal
risultato perché sennò vivi una vita che
non ti piace Spero che sia stato chiaro
il concetto è non so che non lo so che
cazzo sto facendo Non lo so Non lo so ci
sto provando sto sperimentando perché
non sono uno che sta con le mani in mano
perché mi annoio e quindi vediamo
vediamo varie cose Vediamo che cosa
posso fare datemi dei consigli Però un
video Tanto siamo tra di noi ragazzi
Questa è un video un po' così Ciao